[Music]
attack on titan in japanese the attack
titan is literally about aaron attacking
all of humanity as a titan in the end
aaron becomes what he hates the most
it's an anti-war story about a
protagonist that turns out to be the
villain but also the victim of the story
all along and he's probably the most
misunderstood character i have ever seen
so attack on titan is finally over and
the reviews are in and everyone seems to
have hated it i have come across a broad
spectrum of things people didn't like
about how the story wrapped up but the
most commonly named fact i heard was
without any doubt aaron the supposed
main character of the story massacring
his way through the last few arcs
without giving us the big twist at the
end that everyone was apparently hoping
for no satisfying ending no coherent
character development no big aha moment
to reveal that aaron was the good guy
all along that we all wanted him to be
and admittedly i have personally not
been a fan of some of the writing
throughout the story with the mangaka
explicitly stating himself that he had
difficulties with writing and even
understanding his own main character and
yet i do want to argue in this video
that aaron's character was consistent
from start to finish and that his ending
not only makes sense but is actually
just as deep as you were hoping for but
make sure to let me know your
perspective once you've watched it
before we get into it if you want to
relive the story of attack on titan or
simply enjoy the last volume as a whole
now is your chance i've partnered up
with bookwalker an online bookstore and
app for reading manga and light novels
digitally wherever you are not only do
they have many of your favorite manga
and light novels i've personally been
reading tokyo revengers and vinlan saga
recently but they also have countless
other less known but nonetheless
fantastic stories for you to explore as
well i genuinely really like the overall
reading experience and their coin system
gives you the chance to get big
discounts on future purchases and right
now until the 27th of september they're
running their fantasy fare 2021 campaign
where you can get 45 coin back on
volumes 1 to 3 and 30 on any sequel
volumes for many of their stories
including attack on titan and on top if
you use my code ohara you'll even get
600 yen so about 5 bucks off as a new
user link in the description below so
get reading but not until you finish
this video in many ways i think that
eren and more generally attack on titan
as a whole fell prey to its own success
it was the story that popularized anime
and manga outside of japan as probably
no other story before even more than big
shots like dragon ball one piece or
naruto pushing the genre into the main
stream
and so many people me included put
attack on titan side by side with many
other shonen and other mainstream
stories as a more dark and bloody
version of them and some people kept
that up until the very end until the
very last chapter however when the
larger world and narrative behind the
story was finally revealed with marley
and elia and all the political social
and moral implications around them maybe
later than necessary i understood that
attack on titan does not only not belong
into the shonen genre but in many ways
uses the anime and manga format to
depict an incredibly dark and depressing
story
if you think this has a happy ending
you haven't been paying attention so in
retrospect it does make a lot of sense
to me that the creator hajime isayama
was completely taken aback by its
international success
now while we all knew that aaron jaeger
was no conventional shonen hero isayama
never saw him as any sort of hero for
the story in the first place he is the
protagonist for sure but as it turned
out after the time skip we were watching
the story of the complex and morally
grave villain of the story the backstory
and ultimately the downfall of the man
who not only killed a character here and
there or even a crowd of bystanders but
80 percent of the world's population can
we appreciate for a second just how
bizarre that wiki entry is
so yes my opinion is that aaron is both
morally gray and capable of good but
looking at the end result nonetheless
the villain of the story he is
admittedly though a villain that tries
to be the hero though he ultimately
fails
eren is a beautiful example of the rare
negative character arc negative not
because the arc is bad but in the sense
that the character develops but instead
of growing to become a better person he
grows to become a worse one let me
explain normally a positive arc that we
know from most of our main characters
has the heroes start from a negative
place he has some sort of belief or
ideal that has a negative impact on him
or in the worst case those around him as
well so he does need to change and so
throughout the story he might have
moments of darkness and failure but
genuinely moves in the right direction
until in the end when the big moment of
truth comes he finally understands his
big flaw and makes the right choice
becoming a better person and giving us
the happy ending we want a negative arc
such as aarons is the inversion of this
the character starts with a similar flaw
but from a much more positive looking
start point aaron always has his angry
and violent sight and difficulties being
vulnerable but his hard work and
determination to protect his friends and
fight for freedom at least at the start
seemed to point him into the right
direction however instead of moving into
the right direction we see aaron slowly
falling deeper and deeper into his
feelings of rage and helplessness
punctured by the occasional moments of
positivity for instance during his fight
with annie after arming sacrificed
himself for his sake or during the
events in the crystal cave
but despite these moments of insight
aaron digresses further and further away
from his original goal until finally
he's faced with the ultimate choice to
murder 80 percent of humanity or
simply
stop and he chooses the rumbling over
his humanity contrary to many others i
believe that in many ways aaron has the
most linear development out of all
characters in the last part of the story
and he still wants to run away back to
her father because that's what he told
her to do when he was a little girl
mikasa starts with the desire to have a
normal family with aaron and after all
she went through she is still
co-dependent on him until the very end
armen still sees himself as weak and
unimportant despite wielding the
strongest titan and being a commander in
the army it's a story about kids turned
into soldiers that can't grow up
properly and move on from their
childhood ideals and beliefs due to all
the cruelty and violence around them
something that falco and gabi represent
in the latest arc by literally mirroring
aaron and kohl
these characters don't follow a
character arc as much as they follow a
character cycle breaking out of their
bad habits and beliefs only to fall
right back into them and even though you
may or may not like it and believe me i
totally get it i prefer happy ends
myself but this has nothing to do with
just bad writing it is unconventional
yes but not bad so how did it all come
to this in the end one of my favorite
things about attack on titan's writing
was the shamelessly abrupt change of
narrative perspective from before to
after the time skip for the first three
seasons until we reach the sea we
basically share the same misleading and
propagandized perspective of our main
protagonists the premise at the
beginning seems pretty clear all that is
left of humanity lives inside the walls
of the last standing bastion facing the
inhuman and soulless titans that with
their grotesque looks and movements hunt
humans attack on titan seemed a pretty
clear setup to me for humanity versus
the monsters
okay so now eden can transform into a
titan but but it's okay he only uses
this power to fight the evil monsters ah
but then we find out that he's actually
not the only one that can do this
actually it turns out all the titans
were actually not soulless beasts to
begin with but people turned beasts
against their own will
so it's actually attack on humans i
guess and now there's a lot of intrigue
and political games going on and the
ones in power choose to leave thousands
of their soldiers and civilians to be
slaughtered by the titans rather than
letting anyone learn the truth slowly
but steadily season by season the horror
of the titans makes way to the horror of
people and season 3 literally ends with
world war ii imagery leaving the titan
powers as a mere weapon of mass
destruction
with the time skip just as aaron and co
we suddenly break free from the world
view which propaganda has been spoon fed
to us since chapter 1. as it turns out
what we thought to be the very last
resort of humanity was actually just a
tiny island in a world rich with people
and cultures and so attack on titan
suddenly is not a story about humans
fighting monsters anymore it's a story
about humans fighting humans or monsters
fighting monsters a story about racism
and war and how they lead to a
never-ending cycle of hatred and
oppression the titans in the end only
exist as a tool of oppression and the
cause of racism in this world which is
ultimately why their true origin and the
secret behind their creation doesn't
matter in the end
now the clear catalyst for aaron's
inability to grow is the loss of his
mother having her unconditional love
taken away traumatized him so extremely
that it makes him incapable of growing
into a true adult however we do know
that aaron already carried anger and
violence inside him when he murdered the
two traffickers who tried to take mikasa
now both us and mikasa take this as a
pure act of kindness however the version
of aaron that gently wraps the scarf
around her head the version that mikasa
believes him to be until the very end
and that undoubtedly exists somewhere
inside aaron never makes it past his
anger and this is the key to eren's last
words at the end that left so many
people disappointed the truth here
however is that aaron never had a clear
motivation for his actions to begin with
yes he wanted to protect his friends but
above all aaron had always hated the
fact that he had no agency in control
over this cruel world
he was so traumatized by not being able
to do anything about his mother being
killed that he literally took control of
the world to stop the world controlling
him instead of facing and accepting his
own humanity and vulnerability he
selfishly tries to control everything
and everyone around him if you read
closely in the last chapter eden changes
his reasoning from i was doing it all to
set you guys up as the heroes of the
world two i would have done it anyways
even if you didn't come to stop me to i
don't know i just wanted to iden makes
and always has made up stories and
reasons for his atrocities looking for a
way to give them a greater meaning when
there really is none that's why it only
makes sense that there was no great
twist to his plan at the end eren felt
justified in his actions at every step
of the way if he really did it all for
his friends why did he hurt them just as
armin said to get that choice that
ultimate freedom that he always wanted
he takes it away from everyone around
him
[Music]
so the fact that eren's reasoning
doesn't make sense is actually not a
flaw but a fundamental part of his
personality he begins his life with the
words you were born into this world
you're free to live however you want and
ends his life wishing that he was never
born in the first place and that is the
ultimate tragedy of his character arc
not that it ever was inevitable he would
eventually do all these things but
because it was not and aaron choose to
do them anyway instead of choosing
literally anything else as you know
there were plenty of options for him to
just stop and everyone was literally
begging him to do so and so despite
claiming mikasa and armin to be the
reasons behind all of his actions they
weren't because he was incapable of
making this simple choice to be with
them and grow up with them which
ultimately is all they ever wanted from
him
all eren ever wanted was agency and
control but what he really needed was
allowing himself to be vulnerable and
accept the unconditional love he had
from armin and mikasa unconditional love
that his brother ziki was denied all his
life
what unites the tragic stories of eren
and ziki and reiner and many others is
that they all act based on a sense of
entitlement because of what has happened
to them as children they all were
oppressed and the victim of a brutal
life and they all used that fact as
justification for the actions even past
the point where they had gained so much
power that they themselves had become
the oppressors
[Music]
all of them committing war crimes and
genocides still feeling like they are
the true victims here i mean erin gets
the lesson that he's not the only one
that is suffering in this world shoved
in his face over and over and over again
but right until the end he fails to see
the true feelings of the people around
him because he won't even allow himself
to face his own fears hopes and dreams
he rejects armin's dreams even though
they used to be his own just as he
rejects mikasa's love even though he
clearly loves her as well
there is definitely room to criticize
the writing and attack on titan a brutal
anti-war story about monster adults
creating monster children in a world
where the motivations and beliefs of
every single character comes from their
traumatizing childhoods
[Music]
however i think you can't deny the
beauty in aaron literally becoming the
attack titan that threatens to wipe out
all of humanity exactly what the story
seemed to be about at the start he
becomes the essence of what he used to
hate the most a giant monster that toys
with the lives of everyone for
apparently no good reason whatsoever
[Music]
it in becoming the enemy of humanity
then is the tragic story of a
traumatized kid robbed of his chance for
a happy and normal life by the cruel
world around him and so the unseeming
but quite bright happy end of aaron's
gruesome arc as a character then is that
ultimately his dream of getting rid of
all the titans the symbol of oppression
come to an end with his own death and
mikasa who was unable to break free from
her codependent love for him until that
point is the tragic hero who takes the
life of the man she loves still seeing
in him the beauty of the world that eden
never could